the war in ukraine has altered the lives
of millions and has sent prices for
goods like oil and natural gas
skyrocketing around the world
but the worst may be yet to come
could the war prevent ukraine from
harvesting food this year
how important are ukraine and russia to
the global food supply
and how could this lead to further
social unrest
this is what if and here's what would
happen if ukraine couldn't grow food
this summer
ukraine has been called the bread basket
of the world together with russia the
two nations account for about 30 percent
of global wheat exports
not only that but 12
of all the calories consumed around the
world
yet since the beginning of russia's
invasion in february
both countries have been effectively cut
off from exporting food
millions of ukrainians have been forced
to flee their homes or join in the
defense effort
the conflict has also physically
disrupted many of the country's
essential fuel supply and trade routes
and russia
russia's under heavy economic sanctions
that make exporting food enormously
difficult
so with the timeline to de-escalation
still unclear
could the world be on the verge of
global hunger
ukraine is one of the largest exporters
of wheat corn and sunflower seeds and
this year ukrainian harvests are
estimated to be down about 30 percent
right away this would cause a ripple
effect around the world
some places would be more directly
affected by this than others
particularly countries in northern
africa and central asia if you live in
armenia mongolia or eritrea
you could see your wheat supply
completely cut off
and finding another source wouldn't be
so easy
you'd now be forced to compete with more
economically powerful nations that can
afford to pay higher prices
turkey iran and bangladesh import over
60 percent of their wheat from russia
and ukraine and egypt depends on these
countries for a staggering 80 percent of
its supply
the price of wheat is already up 69
within the last year and with an ongoing
effect on the supply chain
those prices could continue to climb
the longer the war continues the more
serious this wheat situation gets
these higher prices wouldn't be limited
to just wheat
livestock around the world consumes a
lot of grain
animal feed prices would skyrocket and
because of that meat all over the world
would start getting pricey too
and it gets worse
russia and belarus are two of the
largest exporters of potash
which is an important ingredient in
fertilizers
now both of those countries are under
sanctions russia for starting the war
and belarus for supporting russia's
aggression against a sovereign country
all this means that brazil which depends
on these two countries for about half of
its potash supply would have to cough up
more cash too
so you'd start to see the price of your
favorite coffee soy and beef products
climbing higher and higher
disruption to the fertilizer trade would
have enormous effects beyond just rising
costs
this could seriously threaten the global
food system
farmers all around the world depend on
fertilizers to grow their food
without it you'd see massive declines in
food production of all kinds
and with that we'd now be in really
dangerous territory
countries would begin to limit their
food exports in favor of making sure
there's enough supply to feed their own
citizens
in many places there simply wouldn't be
enough money or supply to guarantee this
for potentially millions of people bread
being expensive would no longer be the
core issue
now they may not have any bread at all
that could lead to social and political
upheavals
many countries subsidize bread costs to
avoid this very circumstance
riots would break out and many
governments would violently crack down
on their own people to maintain order
and organizations that normally rush to
aid in these moments would be in trouble
too
before the war the united nations world
food program relied on ukraine for half
its grain supply to feed starving people
around the world
now around 45 percent of ukrainians are
worried about not finding enough food
for themselves
in times of stability having such an
interconnected global economy can
provide people with so many things but
when something like russia's invasion of
ukraine disrupts that it reveals how
fragile this system is
our food supply chains could be damaged
for years to come
and
things could still get worse
like if russia launches a nuke
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you